Jeffrey Dean Morgan has expressed
interest in being on the show in season
three um have you have you taken his
desire to be on the show to heart I
absolutely have there's one role we're
already talking about you know he has to
we have to figure we have to like
coordinate because you know he's on he's
on The Walking Dead
so he has he has another home but we
already talked about one role and there
might be a potential other that we're
talking about but like we we are just
this past week we were literally texting
back and forth about trying to figure
out how to get him on the show so I
don't think it's a done deal yet but um
the will is there and we're both talking
about yeah is it one of those things
where he really just wants to play any
role are you trying to think about
something badass I mean III thought
about a role for him that we're talking
about but I'm you know but but you know
we're just still it's really embryonic
as I said in all that season 3 stuff is
really embryonic so there's room for us
to just figure something out